you know whenever people gripe about
that dub Goku being like Superman they
always bring up the same scene I am
protector of the innocent I am the light
in the darkness I am truth but me
personally this one takes the cake by a
mile it's the scene in the Saiyan Arc
where Goku asks Krillin not to kill
Vegeta in the original Japanese and in
the manga Goku requests this because he
selfishly wants to train more and fight
him again it's Goku's first subtle
indication that he is coming to terms
with his Saiyan Roots but the dub
completely ignores this let him go
Krillin
show
it what
it means to be merciful we're showing
him that there's another way a better
way it's the most Superman action and it
drives me insane that dub only viewers
are robbed of this genuinely interesting
character moment from Goku as always
though at least Kai got it right